o soir persone belle non so se avete mai
sentito nelle storie strappalacrime che
oggi ne vivremo un sacco
esiste un gioco che si chiama porca
vacca non si chiama così mi si è spento
il telefono c'è un gioco che si chiama
hince life che ti crea delle vite storie
cose partiamo new life stipendi c'è
questa roba che tu clicchi e lui ti crea
un mondo
siamo in partita storta new life
perfetto ma è start è una roba molto
strana però secondo me na figata
proviamo a vedere random a new life
perfetto da sono però se tua madre
lavora in autostrada non è che mi puoi
mettere pubblicitaria a new life
ok siamo nati sono nato maschio juve
bonn e mail in francia mi chiama che
sfiga porca donna sci in tutti i paesi
del mondo proprio in francia un bug e
tom ti chiami il neo morel e 6 francese
bene ei d'armi chiave va dal 51 anni e
faccio lucas suonati da fare troppo
tardi age non succede niente non succede
niente non succede niente
i tuoi parenti vogliono organizzati una
festa di compleanno vuoi farne una
perché gli altri anni non me l'hanno
fatta che sono stronzi certo sei stato
bulli dato alla tua festa di compleanno
ma no ma come ma che vita di merda siamo
partiti malissimo porte o assali assali
non capisco la metà di quello che ci
sono scritte comunque come fai ad averli
assaltati ad averli strozzati ed averli
tirati di pugni ai 6 anni
però va bene un tornado f4 ha colpito è
stato riportato con una velocità di 158
miglia orarie mazza otto persone sono
morte e 49 sono state ferite
per carità di dio mi dispiace un sacco
mamme che cosa cazzo me ne frega ce ne
senso al mio personaggio fittizio in
questo tornato fittizio che cosa minchia
gliene frega lui broom a 18 anni stai
per fare il test della patente che
miscredenti io no 23 ancora non ce l'ho
lo farai sì
si hai fallito tutte scrivi da allora
avevo un vizio mi succede sempre ok
qual è la tua sessualità e lo stai
scoprendo a 23 anni qual è la tua
sessualità io comunque sono etero ma
l'ho scoperto quando avevo sei sono
eterosessuale bene avanti avanti love
mica finalmente la patata 25 anni porca
vacca non ha francese una baguette on
si chiama adele thomas già meno male che
ho preso thomas si chiamava delle pietro
era veramente un casino sei fidanzato
con una dele va bene ciao adele its
baguette ai 26 27 28 29 mio padre è
morto ma no gli 80 anni a ok 80 già vero
che mi hanno avuto tardi quindi è morto
80 mazza mi ha lasciato 94 mila dollari
faccio luca 31festival season al
megabyte festival ci vai sì due persone
sono morte non ci vado più a mia madre
morta all 81 anni ma no ma no
mia madre mi ha lasciato 0 povera ma
vabbè non fa niente però porca vacca
puoi cadere tutti sono morti sono alzo e
in città mia moglie e mauro propaganda
roba per la tristezza ha messo in città
mi voglio avere farlo adottare a bore
manovra anche pochi keep tienilo ok
decidete di tenere il bambino se per tre
ne ho fatti in un colpo solo triplex
credo che siano tre figli in una botta
sola faccia lunga non lo facevi da tanto
tempo immagino numero 1 bambino numero
uno ha una femmina a amanda francese
purtroppo amanda francese purtroppo e
poi mio cognome pino il conta di
contadino segue
una si chiama amanda francese purtroppo
la tramanda e l'altro pino al contadino
l'aver tutte femmine sono anche pino al
contadino e una femmina prove mi è
venuta la febbre
la tua fidanzata è incinta o avete rotto
gas usato lo stoke hondo keep tieni il
bambino age è un maschio o ovviamente
maschio chiamiamo usate il preservativo
39 40 41 42 che un tornado f5 ha colpito
la russia 1366 morti
vabbè facciamo come avanti avanti avanti
avanti avanti cioè cinquant'anni anch'io
my daughter pino il contadino è
diventato si e graduato cioè promosso
che figo avanti avanti avanti ma è da 8
alpino contadino claudio addis e
graduato al college my son usate il
preservativo se graduato nella scuola
secondaria
adesso quello che fanno i figli minico
vedi un'accusa o gesù venne una
prostituta quarantenne donna sulla
strada all'angolo che cosa fai
sollecita argomenta assalta ignora vabbè
dai baci vacci tu e il tuo partner
avete litigato beh grazie al kit 57 anni
sono a [ __ ] alla madre degli haters
ancora viva nel 2004 7 adele e thomas ha
delle thomas si chiama così
brock up with you e non sono più
fidanzato va bene ci ha messo un anno
per lasciarmi in teoria ti va bene
arthur si sta facendo mia figlia
no è morto a 62 anni per ripert of rack
ipertrofiche cardiomiopatia ma che merda
ma come sono morto 62 ma dai
al suo posto deciderò se continuare con
i miei figli o se fare una random live
no vabbè parlando a un live no è stato
fighissimo durata poco fa figo va bene
sono una donna e sono nata a cipro mi
hanno chiamato lume yitzhak ike la manis
che non è un nome scientifico di una
pianta anche se potrebbe sembrare il mio
nome è stata nel 93 va bene mio padre e
marco calcola manis mia madre rumena è
mai chiamato come mia madre che mi
chiama quanto a fantasia acciaio age un
anno le anni carni trani 56 anni è stata
la scuola da sette anni 80 che che vita
bella e una ragazza che ha o che posso
uscire fidanzarmi gaufre adult se non a
rilascio in chip con maria grande maria
bene che me la dà lo zimbabwe ha
dichiarato guerra l'australia così ho
sempre prendere la patente la fai
sì
non puoi permettere ma no ma come allora
prendere ormai sta patente che sfiga
cielo un cazzo la mia vita ho avuto un
attacco di cuore 42 anni ok no è morta
48 per un attacco di cuore ancora
attacchi di cuore al mio funerale ci
sono stati i miei parenti mio partner
mano ma come i miei genitori sono morto
prima a farci toccare palla
roma isaca reclama nice è morta di
attacco di mano come attacco di cuore
aveva già avuto prima sede che giocava
un sacco di horror land of life inizia
nella per mi dispiace perchè abbiamo
perfezionato sommato in zambia in zambia
c'è la pubblicità
mi chiamo surya solare in va bene age
age age all influenza age
non ho più l'influenza è durato un anno
l'influenza come te queste indicazioni
per strada cosa vuoi fare
ignorarli fare il cattivo fare il buono
fra il buono i tuoi amici vogliono
versare la porta e scappare via lo fai
si no mi ha preso la polizia ma come e
perché non è un reato bussare alle porte
scappa vuole ergastolo cioè io ve lo
dico già drive in o teste patente numero
3 ma basta
ma basta perché mi possono sempre ma
porca vacca non hai le qualifiche per
andare all'università vuoi andare mai
abbastanza qualifiche però
dall'università ok io non ce l'avevo può
iniziare a fumare sigarette no
università che fai e l'università di
a parte facciamo i quadri sera sto
studiando arte hai conosciuto un maschio
chiamato lucus c'è ma si vabbè però i
nomi normali regala porca eva morta
nazionalità lituano 32 anni ci ha 10
anni pd me no ti attacchi ugazzi che
hanno offerto dello smooth a droghe ma
perché mi offrono sigarette droga e se
vivo in zambia no una volta di george e
alla mia ma [ __ ] bene solo perché
non so come chiamarlo quindi va bene tre
anni più piccolo george ama la casoria
la minchia de gioia ha sbroccato cioè
chi ha lasciato stronzo
ok un ragazzo chiamato michael good da
banham bosi va bene cofra dei sono in
raggi nation chip con michael 28 29
la finlandia dichiarato guerra a cipro
proprio a me ok sei passato vicino alla
scena del crimine ci dai un occhio se
sono stato in galera sei anni per
ostruzione alla giustizia per ostacolo
alla giustizia
cosa ho visto una scena di chi non è che
sono stato io ma come ti offrono
dell'eroina ma basta in prigione pur e
basta ti hanno offerto una birra o
questo la bevo state craft beer sheva
una rivolta in prigione cosa farai joint
ignora joint mi sono tagliato il petto
mi sono tagliato un orecchio sono fatto
male al bacino
mi sono tagliato un dente mi sono fatto
prendere a testate age michael da
bambozzi broccato with you ma proprio
adesso che sono uscito ho finito la mia
penney tema dai vada va a cagare un
aveva mollato prima fatto senza andata
mignot tutti gli anni lo dico io hai
conosciuto mark o clerc e che ha 66 anni
muore domani quindi cosa ci sto insieme
io non vado mai in pensione ma perché
era un ex galeotto 71 sono morta 72 anni
vabbè di cause naturali
bene ragazzi questo era is life ho fatto
un po di ho fatto cose ragazzi io spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto realtà non
so cosa ho appena giocato quindi non so
spiegarmi bene però è sempre bello dar
vita a cose quindi ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto come
mi piace avere giustizia se non sei
obiettivi chiari e noi ci vediamo un pò
seguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]